Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from some
more people you can get in touch with me through
our discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
Let's go next to Aaron from Los Angeles, California.
Aaron, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Oh, David.
I just had, I guess, like some questions regarding
FCC standards and everything like, do you
think that media companies?
Do you think the FCC should bring back the
fairness doctrine that they had back in the
eighties in order to make, I guess, representation
of diverse ideas on all networks more palatable?
And secondly, like this is someone that has
a little bit of experience and I guess community
radio.
I'm very, very skeptical of adding new regulations
on, like anything new FCC regulations in particular.
Yeah, I
Speaker 1: think the cat is out of the bag
on this.
I do not think bringing because the media
landscape has changed so much.
I've said before, I don't think bringing back
the fairness doctrine is really going to achieve
what maybe we hope it would achieve so much
now of media consumption is internet based
in all ways.
Even people in cars, cars now have hot spots,
and I do not think that in a way that is subject
to FCC jurisdiction, you're really going to
be able to accomplish what one imagines you
might be able to accomplish with it.
So I think we need to be fighting this in
other ways.
And you know, we've talked before about what
those ways are, but I would not waste.
I believe it's a waste of energy to focus
on an FCC based fairness doctrine to sort
of like, fix the problems in media right now.
Speaker 2: I agree, and I also just think
that like a lot of the just outright regulations
that have that, the FCC has just more harms
independent creators and independent outlets
and university outlets as opposed to, you
know, the major conservative political talk
networks that have been getting away through
loopholes for decades.
Speaker 1: Yes, there's no doubt about that,
and I think that this is really going to come
from, you know, and I hate to say this because
it's like sometimes it feels like if you just
put in some law, you fix everything when the
real solution is more complicated.
The media problem is heavily based on such
a total lack of media literacy in the country,
where if we had better education around media
literacy, we would not even need to be thinking
about a lot of these other solutions that
are much more legally based, and it's a long
term solution.
I know you can't fix that overnight, but I
continue to believe that's where the solution
lies.
Speaker 2: It's just so puzzling to me how
that's just such a major thing, how media
literacy is just not possible, especially
because in American education systems, they
prioritize so much about reading and writing.
Yes, a young age from kindergarten, but it's
not translating over.
Our English education isn't teaching us these
types of skills at all.
Speaker 1: And case in point, there there
are countries that start teaching, reading
and writing later than the U.S. that everybody
still ends up at the same level.
But there are media literacy ends up ahead.
And I believe part of it is this is just an
opinion based on some things I've read at
ages four or five six.
Instead of jumping in prematurely into reading
and writing.
There's more about thinking, and I think it
is something that just should be thought about
is all I'm saying.
Speaker 2: OK, that's fair.
Yeah.
Well, thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Aaron from Los Angeles,
thanks very much.
I do appreciate that.
Great to hear from you.
Let's go next to where do we want to go next?
I mean, there's just there's just so many
people that that want to talk.
How about how about Colin from Iowa?
Colin, you're next.
Speaker 2: Hello, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Wow, this is really an honor, David, sir,
I've been such a fan of the show.
The honor is my my my main choice for any
news that I do, sir.
Beautiful.
Oh, wow.
This actually happened, I'm I'm sorry, I'm
a little starstruck.
You're doing great.
Speaker 1: You're doing great.
Did you have a question today?
Speaker 2: I do have a question.
OK.
It's a little bit on the lighter side, I'd
say.
I mean, obviously I would talk about COVID
or whatever, but this is just something that
I've heard recently among, like a lot of liberals
or whatever, it's about, OK, well, I'm from
Iowa, obviously, and marijuana is illegal
there.
So I was like thinking, I think I said something
along the lines of like, what if Biden were
to like Pres.
Biden were to decriminalize marijuana if it's
decriminalized in a lot of states?
And from what I've heard, a lot of the decriminalized
states because I also live in Illinois like
Illinois, is my second home, I guess you can
say.
And like, it's it's it's legal here, and there
really hasn't been a problem there.
So what do you think about like the decriminalization
of marijuana nationally?
And if Joe Biden were to do that, how do you
think that would affect his popularity?
Speaker 1: I think his popularity would increase
significantly if he were to decriminalize.
I think there's a lot of people who would
prefer that Joe Biden federally legalize marijuana.
I think there are different opinions as to
whether he could do that.
But aside from that, it's it's just not going
to be the next step.
I think the next step, the logical next step
in the progression would be decriminalization.
I think it would be incredibly popular overall.
If he did it, there would be people that are
mad for sure.
But when you're talking about decriminalizing,
you're not saying legal recreational pot shops
on every corner the way right wingers love
to fearmonger about, so they wouldn't be able
to do that.
They might say it's the first step towards
that, but I think it would be popular.
I would love for him to do it, and I am 100
percent in favor of that.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I totally agree, David.
And for one thing, for a living in Iowa, like
I'll reveal a little bit about myself.
I live in the quad cities, so I'm on the Iowa
side of the quad cities and I don't know anybody
personally that smokes.
But from what I've heard a lot, a lot of like
the people on my campus, they will like drive
over just a few miles just to get to like
Rock Island and Moline.
And then they get the pot and then they bring
it back to Davenport.
I think that is just kind of ridiculous.
Speaker 1: So now I just want to make sure
I understand because some people may not be
familiar with all of the you're saying they
drive over into Illinois to buy the legal
pot.
Speaker 2: Yes, the quad cities.
There's an Iowa side in Illinois.
Got it.
Since the Illinois side is the legal side,
you would just drive over and then pick it
up, right?
Yeah, that's that's just a Quad City secret
for you if
Speaker 1: you got it.
All right.
Well, the secret is now out very, very much.
Appreciate the call.
And yes, certainly sorry.
A little quick on the trigger finger there.
Very much appreciate the call.
I am in favor of decriminalization and legalization.
I think I am for both.
I am for both